it is my very sad duty to update this
afternoon
police officers searching a wooded area
close to where Constance and Mark Gordon
were arrested discovered the remains of
a baby
a post-mortem examination will be held
in due course
a crime scene is in place and work at
the location is expected to continue for
some time
this is an outcome that myself and that
many officers who have been part of this
search had hoped would not happen
I recognize the impact this news will
have on the many people who have been
following the story closely
and can assure them that we will do
everything we possibly can to establish
what has happened
Constance Martin
and Mark Gordon remain in custody after
the application for the extension of
their detention for a further 36 hours
was sought and granted by Brighton
magistrates Court